the live stream it's been a little while
since the last one I think it's been
about a week I deliberately didn't
stream for a week because you know
sometimes I feel like I'm I'm streaming
too much and the way I gauge that is
number one the number of people on the
streams and number two the interest in
me opening the phone lines visa vie a
new member challenge which is usually
ten new members and with the size
audience we get on the streams if I'm
not doing too many streams we should be
able to get those ten new members and
open the phone lines if there's not
enough demand for that when we have like
a thousand people on the stream it
probably means I'm streaming too much
and sadly last time we only got to nine
out of ten new members the phone lines
didn't get open I ended the stream and
cried in the next room over for about a
half hour because I was so triggered
about people invaded my safe space and
didn't become members so anyway I took a
week off
I've been busy anyway I was away all
weekend and I'm back here and it's a
stream and we have a ton of stuff to
talk about I already see people trolling
the chat before the stream even started
we have stories to talk about we will
take super chats I may open the phone
lines I'll get to that momentarily but
there is just major major major news
happening here regarding two sets of
subpoenas that have been okayed to go
forward which I'm going to talk about so
I'll get right into it rather than
filibustering and talking about
memberships and trolling and all sorts
of different stuff I'll just get right
into the content and then later we'll
see what people what else people are
hoping I will do during the stream take
phone calls play chess against people in
the audience what whatever else okay so
we'll get into it but the big news is
reported by the New York Times not only
have House Democrats moved forward on
demanding six years of Donald Trump's
tax returns from the IRS under subpoena
they have also approved the use of
subpoena to obtain a full unredacted
Robert Muller report which at this point
I mean I'll go into it in detail
tomorrow
it's not clear what we're going to get
it's not clear who we're going to get it
from it's not clear who is going to get
a chance to redact stuff before it comes
out we just don't know so subpoena power
it may well be happening so let's go
through this one piece at a time because
there's a lot here first on the IRS
stuff the chairman of the House Ways and
Means Committee using a little-known
provision in the federal tax code
formally requested today that the IRS
hand over six years of President Trump's
personal and business tax returns
starting what is likely to be a
momentous fight with his administration
I think this is a worthwhile fight even
if the Democrats lose because reminding
the voting public that oh yeah we
haven't we still haven't seen his tax
returns is a great thing to do in terms
of electoral politics by the way
Bernie's gonna have to release his okay
Bernie is not exempt from this
I know Bernie hasn't released his tax
returns he said he's going to he should
and I'm going to hold him to the same
standard don't you worry we're
absolutely going to Congressman Richard
II Neil who I know personally he used to
be my congressman he's been on the show
I've talked to him on air and off air
really good guy
Democrat of Massachusetts hand-delivered
a two-page letter laying out the request
to the Internal Revenue Service
Commissioner ending months of
speculation about when he would do so
and almost certainly prompting a legal
challenge from the Trump administration
responding to questions from reporters
in the Oval Office Trump suggested he
would fight the requests because he said
he was being audited still using that
excuse I guess when you have a name you
are audited but until such such time as
I'm not under audit I would not be
inclined to do that of course Michael
Cohen to the extent that we believe
Michael Cohen said he is not aware of
Donald Trump being under audit and I
believe he would know and that is not a
reason to not release your tax returns
there's absolutely nothing about being
under audit if it's true that would
preclude him from releasing his tax
returns and again this is not what Trump
wants these are subpoenas and this is
ultimately going to be a legal battle
not Trump is under audit and he doesn't
want the stuff release so that's that's
number one related to the taxes let me
see if there's anything relevant here
okay this is now part 2 so that this was
part 1 but now it has become part 2
because if the tax return component
other panels controlled by House
Democrats were flexing their muscles the
House Judiciary Committee this morning
authorized its chairman Jerry Nadler to
use a subpoena to try to force the
Justice Department to give Congress a
full copy of the special counsels report
and all of the underlying evidence used
to reach his conclusions on Russian
interference in the 2016 election now
this is really important and I think
it's in the second paragraph the
chairman of the House Oversight and
Reform Committee said he would soon ask
for a vote on a subpoena of his own okay
no this has enough this is a different
thing here's the point I wanted to make
the House Committee today authorized
chairman Nadler to use subpoena power to
get an unredacted version of the Moller
report they have not issued that
subpoena okay Jerry Nadler said and
maybe I can even pull up actually I
don't think it is on his Twitter account
Jerry Nadler has now been authorized by
the committee to use subpoena power
should he determine it necessary he said
and it's been reported by a couple of
different media outlets that he is going
to wait to see if William bar gives him
a a version of the Moller report that is
unredacted enough to be considered a
full version before he makes a decision
about utilizing that subpoena power so
we don't actually know yet whether that
subpoena is going to be issued or not
okay let's continue with this article
unlike the chairman of other committees
mr. Neal is not relying on a subpoena or
standard congressional processes he is
invoking an authority and shrined in the
tax code granted only to the tax writing
committees in Congress that gives the
chairman of the House Ways and Means
Committee and the Senate Finance
Committee the power to request tax
information on any filer mr. Neal gave
the agency until April 10 to comply with
the request and if he receives the
information he will then confidentially
review it with his committee staff let
me look at the calendar because when is
that the tenth is oh it's a week from
today
Wednesday okay so I'm not hosting the
show on Tuesday Bendixon will be filling
in for me because I'll be heading out to
Las Vegas for a progressive media
meeting of the minds at the mass torts
made perfect conference hosted by
attorney Mike Papantonio a great friend
of the show for a very long time so I'm
guessing we will learn whether this
request has been fulfilled declined or
sort of in limbo either on Wednesday the
10th or Thursday the 11th and I will be
hosting both of those shows so that's
good I don't like missing big new stuff
that goes on what else do we have here
the provision dates in some form to the
Teapot Dome scandal of Warren G
Harding's administration at least on its
face gives the Trump administration
little room to decline a request like
mr. Neal's it only says the Treasury
secretary shall furnish the information
now of course the Treasury secretary is
hand-picked a hand-picked Trump
loyalists so we will see what happens
the most likely scenario is not that the
Treasury secretary says to Richard Neal
our friend here you go here's Trump's
taxes the most likely scenario is that
some kind of emergency injunction or
delay is granted somewhere along the
line on the basis of the tax returns
potentially being injurious to Trump
which of course raises the question why
would they be injurious now I don't know
if the majority of our audience thinks
that Donald Trump's taxes would expose
criminality I don't think they would I
think the most likely scenario is that
Donald Trump's tax is exposed that he's
not nearly as wealthy as he claims to be
Michael Cohen has asserted and others
believe it is credible that Donald Trump
inflates his net worth for the purposes
of Forbes rankings and and you know
obtaining loans and then for tax
purposes decreases the the value of his
assets or the value of buildings
whatever the case may be I think that's
the most likely scenario it would be an
ego damage to Donald Trump but I don't
I think the most likely scenario here is
that Donald Trump's any criminality is
going to be exposed by Trump's tax
returns I think the financial fraud
money laundering all of that stuff is
happening more than likely at the
corporate level and number two in ways
that would be sort of shielded from
Donald Trump's personal taxes did I just
freeze there I hope I'm not freezing
there seems to be something kind of
weird going on with the connection here
let me know in the chat if people if I'm
freezing or something like that con
artists as president did I freeze I know
there's a slight delay no Jeb Bush so
glad to have Jeb Bush here Jeff Jeb Bush
says I did not freeze all right I guess
I didn't freeze that's a good thing okay
so that's what's going on with subpoenas
of both or requests of both Donald
Trump's tax returns and an unredacted
molar report the other thing I wanted to
mention and I will be talking about this
tomorrow we talked on today's program
already about how Donald Trump during a
very strange press availability in the
oval office yesterday oh I did freeze
people said I was getting blurry and
froze momentarily okay I hope it doesn't
continue to happen
my CPU usage on the stream is only 6%
because the computer is so powerful that
I'm using it's extraordinarily powerful
but I wonder if like windows pushed an
update or something like that yeah I
don't know what caused that but I do
apologize the this Oval Office moment
yesterday had Donald Trump claiming that
his father was born in Germany which
just isn't true and saying that he wants
to know the oranges rather than the
origins he said it twice and looked
confused visibly confused of the Moller
investigation that wants that
investigated and it was really weird he
also has now said privately that wind
turbines caused cancer via noise and
this is this is just getting
extraordinarily weird and we're going to
talk about that on the program tomorrow
I think the most likely scenario here is
some kind of cognitive decline I'm not
saying
the guy is demented I'm not saying that
he has full-blown Alzheimer's I'm saying
he's in his early 70s he's under a lot
of pressure he's under a lot of stress
and that is an age at which stress
stress and pressure I'm sounding like
him United States of America ruch l'm
that that pressure is something that
could accelerate or exacerbate this mild
sort of pre dementia state that mental
health professionals that I've
interviewed say that he is under I don't
I don't think that we need to look too
much further the what's going on seems
relatively obvious this is
extraordinarily unusual behavior and
Donald Trump now claiming that the noise
from wind turbines can cause cancer and
there's no evidence of that that does
appear that there are effects on birds
for example from these weren't wind
turbines although the number of birds
killed by wind turbines is is less than
the number of birds killed by other
forms of power including coal which
Donald Trump is trying to revive so
we're gonna get into that in detail on
tomorrow's program I don't want to get
ahead of it but certainly a lot a lot a
lot to discuss so let me again welcome
everybody to the livestream we have a
this is really live unless you're
watching a replay which means that you
can participate a couple of ways to
participate in the immediate you can use
super chat to ask questions and send
comments we've got a couple of super
chats one too looks like three that have
come in already that's the dollar sign
at the bottom of the chat window it will
pop up on screen and I will go to those
momentarily if you have a question I
will read it and answer it if you have a
comment I will read it and respond even
more importantly potentially if you're
interested in me opening up the phone
lines when we get 10 new subscribers on
our website david pakman.com slash
membership I will open up the phone
lines and you can call in I see that
there are people that want to call in
and I'm glad to do that we failed we had
like I think 14 or 15 live streams in a
row where we hit 10 new members and I
opened up the live stream of the phone
lines during the live stream
last livestream we fell short we only
had nine new members and it was kind of
disturbing to be quite honest so today
if we get to ten memberships I will open
up the phone lines I have plenty of time
to take a bunch of phone calls to coupon
codes are available and let's see if I
can put those up coupon code number one
is this is 20 20 that'll save you 40%
off of any membership winning if you
want to get a $60 membership for just 25
bucks which i think is extraordinarily
reasonable you can apply the coupon code
save 35 to the $60 a year membership and
that'll give you a $60 membership for
just 25 bucks and it's a great deal you
can keep that price for as long as you
want and again if people want the phone
lines opened we don't ask for a lot if
you can't afford it
please don't contribute because we do
the show for everybody regardless of
whether you can afford it but if you can
throw in a couple bucks a month like
with a 25 dollar a year membership this
is the time to do it and if you include
your area code in your name when you
sign up I will give you priority if and
when we open up the phone phone lines I
will go to you first that's a new thing
that was proposed when you sign up on
our website
either in the first name or last name
field put in your area code and then
when we open up the phone lines I will
see your area code as a member and I
will go to you first lastly don't troll
the live chat I see that there's a lot
of people trolling the live chat and we
do have moderators who are fully
deputized to just ban people and maybe
I'll ban a couple of people just to show
you that I'm not afraid to do it
and lastly using the join button down
below counts if you join as a Youtube
member that counts towards our target of
10 so let's see what's on people's minds
I want to get to some of the super chats
that have been sent in starting with a
horror fan for life who says about the
whole Fox News Mexican country statement
I believe they did it on purpose just to
put more anti Mexican rhetoric out there
Fox is smart yeah I don't know for
people who haven't seen that let me see
if I can pull it up
Fox News Mexican countries let's see if
I can pull it up and show it to you yeah
here it is
so the other day Fox News had this
headline at the bottom of the screen
Trump cuts USA to three Mexican
countries of course what frump did is
cut aid not to three Mexican countries
but three Latin American countries that
were not Mexico and what horror fan for
life here is suggesting is that this was
not an accident that this was actually
something deliberately done by Fox News
to foam and anti Mexican rhetoric I
don't know I think it's more idiocy and
stupidity I actually don't think that it
that it was so calculated but I'm open
to that idea Mark Tenenbaum who I played
against in chess during the last last
livestream and I think I won asks
thoughts on Yang's answers during your
interview yes so I interviewed Andrew
yang twenty20 presidential candidate
yesterday who is getting more and more
attention he was on the Joe Rogan
program he was on all over the place
quite frankly recently and I've been
interviewing him for like a year or more
at this point not to Pat myself on the
back I just think it's cool that we've
actually been talking to someone who's
going to be on the debate stage in the
Democratic primary I questioned him
about my misgivings about the way he's
structuring his universal basic income
proposal his position on tuition at
colleges and universities that are
public paid for through taxation I
talked to him about these allegations
that are floating around that he is some
kind of stealth libertarian or alt-right
guy and I have to say I was pretty
satisfied with his answers I know that
after the fact people wrote in and they
said David you could have pushed him
even further on this issue or that issue
I can always just continue one issue
without dropping it but you know there
were a number of things I wanted to ask
about generally speaking I was pleased
with his answers I don't have to agree
with every single position of his I
think he's an honest actor fundamentally
I don't believe that he's a stealth alt
rightist or libertarian I think he's
made that abundantly clear he's
disavowed sort of implicitly implicitly
positive comments from
people like Richard Spencer for example
I was pleased with his answers generally
speaking
Sabrina Zafar says can you speak in
detail about your change in relationship
or political agreement with Dave Rubin
are you still in touch with Rubin you
know I am not in touch with Dave in any
way personally I'm trying to think the
last the last private contact I had with
Dave Rubin was before I went to LA to
politican where I met Sabrina by the way
and I said I'm gonna be there and I
would love to be on and he said I'm
gonna be away that weekend and then I
got to LA and he announced on the day I
was trying to get on his show that he's
having Tucker Carlson on and I said yeah
I I would've loved to have been on I
said it publicly and he said I'm a bad
person because I did that and so I mean
here's the thing Sabrina um I have no
clue what Dave Rubin thinks of me at
this point I assume you know he used to
say he basically agrees with Bernie on
everything now he says crazy Bernie I my
guess is that he used to agree with me
about a lot of stuff and he probably now
would categorize me in a different way a
more negative way there you know he has
had some I guess he says he's had a
political awakening in his late 30s
that's rare so his politics have changed
if we believe that and mine have not so
that's basically it and I would still be
glad to appear on his program I appear
with people that that have political
disagreements with me all the time last
time I was in LA I did something with
Jesse Lee Peterson I appear with people
who disagree with me on the left the
right whatever I'll appear c.j car sends
a ten Australian dollar super chat
saying keep up the great work Thank You
CJ let me say thank you to a few new
members we I was really bummed out on
the last livestream we didn't hit ten
new members and we failed to open the
phone lines which I'm glad to do at six
one seven eight three zero forty seven
fifty I don't want to fail today and we
have two new members Matthew ray field
has signed up on our website at david
pakman.com slash membership
and gee arse girlfriend has signed up on
our website at david pakman.com slash
membership gr is known for super
chatting completely unintelligible
incoherent rants but we love him because
he so regularly supports the show and gr
s girlfriend holly has signed up by the
way not only can you save a 40% off of
membership if you use the coupon code
this is 20/20 not only can you get a $60
membership for 25 bucks if you use the
coupon code save thirty five if you
include your area code when you sign up
and either the first name or last name
field I don't care which I will write
down your area code on a piece of paper
can you imagine something more arcane
and antiquated I will write your area
code down and you can hear my pen
clicking so that if and when we open the
phone lines everybody who got us to open
the phone lines gets priority okay I
will go to the people who trigger for
lack of a better term the opening of the
phone lines by going to them first if
and when we get those phone lines open
so very very important and exciting
stuff Mel Wilson sends a two dollar
super chat and ask thoughts on a
potential Budaj edge versus pence vice
presidential debate
I think Budaj edge would crush Mike
Pence I mean he would pull him out of a
safe space whether Pence wants it or not
and he would absolutely destroy pence
but I'm not talking about VP yet before
the 2018 midterms I wasn't talking about
the 2020 Democratic primary it was too
early right now I'm not talking about VP
stuff because it's too early and I'm
gonna focus on unpresidential M Anthony
sends a dollar ninety nine super chat a
one euro message came in but was
retracted I don't know from who and I
don't know what they said
Lulu girl sends a 99 cent super chat and
Michael Kings sends a $4 99 cent super
chat did you see the Washington Post
article that claims Bernie is morally
just as bad as Trump it's called Bernie
Sanders Azamat
merged as the Trump of the left yeah let
me let me see if I can pull that up
Washington Post Bernie is the new Trump
I'm gonna search for and see if I can
find it but here it is see if I can get
this article to hold up here oh my
goodness it is just toxic ads everywhere
ads are everywhere and I can't I don't
want to put those on the screen okay
let's take a look at that I'm glad you
mentioned that
and before by the way before I even do
this let me just say thank you to harry
Gilliland Harry Gillen gets us to three
new members tonight if and when we get
to ten new members I will open the phone
lines and if you include your area code
when you sign up coupon codes down below
in the description I will give you
priority on the phone lines we're at
three out of ten three out of ten okay
so let's get to this article this
article in The Washington Post let's see
if I can zoom it so that we can see a
little more of it this is not going well
okay I'm gonna zoom back in because
otherwise we won't be able to read it
Bernie Sanders has emerged as the Donald
Trump of the left it's by Dana Millbank
in politics as in physics every action
has an equal and opposite reaction
hence senator Bernie Sanders emergence
as the Donald Trump of the left
fundraising and polls show that many
Democrats think the best answer to an
angry old white guy with crazy hair New
York accent and flair for demagoguery is
well another angry old white guy with
crazy hair New York accent and flair for
demagoguery it's not difficult to
picture a scenario in which Bernie
captures the Democratic presidential
nomination with the same formula that
worked for Trump but for Trump with
Republicans in 2016 on paper
the independent from Vermont doesn't
make sense Democrats are a party of
youth and he's 77 they're majority
female and he's a man they represent the
emerging multicultural America and he's
white statistically he is the worst
option against Trump an NBC News poll
this week found there are more voters
with concerns about Sanders than with
former Vice President Joe Biden senator
Elizabeth Warren and Senator Kamala
Harris or former representative bateau
O'Rourke yet Sanders has both more money
and movement his can
Payne on Tuesday announced a haul of
eighteen point two million dollars in
the first quarter from five hundred
twenty-five thousand individual
contributors
the other major populist early favorite
Warren has floundered in both money and
popularity listen so I'm not gonna read
this entire thing to you here's the
thing Dana Millbank is ignoring the fact
that someone that didn't fit into the
Republican mold won the Republican
primary in 2016
doesn't mean that anyone who wins the
Democratic primary if Bernie does
without fitting into the Democratic mold
is the same as Trump that's ridiculous
the fact that Bernie's identity may
appear similar to Donald Trump Donald
Trump's number one ignores that people
may be supporting Bernie not because of
his identity or despite it but because
they agree with his policy that is
completely ignored by dana Milbank now
if you want to play the identity game i
disagree that bernie and and donald
trump's identities are the same i've
expressed concerns that maybe going with
another old quote white guy although the
debate over whether Jews or white
continues and it's debate I don't even
want to have right now Bernie Sanders
was not born with a silver spoon in his
mouth and Donald Trump was Bernie
Sanders is Jewish and Donald Trump is
not meaning Bernie Sanders whether he
gets the benefit of white privilege by
presenting as white in modern American
society has a history of familial
oppression that Donald Trump couldn't
possibly understand as a guy who was
born with a silver spoon in his mouth to
Fred Trump who was a wealthy guy to
friedrich trump who came to the united
states from germany not oppressed in the
19th century so if you want to play the
identity game i disagree that bernie and
Trump are the same in terms of identity
other than their age and the fact that
they are both perceived as white in
modern American society but not
incorrectly but that that's what it is
for a long time Jews were not perceived
as white and I think that this entire
argument is absolutely ridiculous and it
just is cynical in the sense that it
ignores the
ability that the reason Bernie's doing
well is not because of her despite his
identity but because people like his
policy and people like his policy
position so I think it's an absolutely
ridiculous article okay let me uh where
do we want to go next let me go back to
Super chats uh-oh and a bunch came in
here let's see let me scroll up Wow a
lot of letteth here it is okay JK says
your videos make me feel like I'm in
school thanks I don't know if that's
good or bad Jake but I appreciate the
support
Lulu girl says I enjoyed your critical
thinking series Thanks
thank you very much Jared Johnson with a
twenty Mexican peso super chat so like
forty to sixty minutes on the hair
everyday
- nice no you know this uh my it really
doesn't take long to maintain this hair
and I'm a one day
we're trying to get them to sponsor the
show I I may one day reveal what hair
product I use I've actually revealed it
before but I won't mention it now all
that happens is I get out of the shower
I slicked it straight back put some of
this product in and then just part it
and then run my hands through it and
then it dries that could be me doing
this could actually be turned into a gif
or a jiff that's all it takes and it
basically stays this way I was just out
in the wind buying some fruit if you can
believe it and it was a mess I came back
got into the studio and just five
seconds and it's ready to go so forth
not I think I'd probably spend about a
minute on my hair each day
James Buchi no how do you feel about
Andrew yang after the last interview do
you still think think he's in your top
three candidates yes I actually already
got a and I think I may have just frozen
momentarily again I actually just got an
earlier super chat about it and I was
pleased with Andrew Yang's answers
yesterday and today on the program and
he is still in in my top three for sure
Geraldine nee Maurice Rua probably the
worst pronunciation ever on the program
is a new member using the join button
down below that's the fourth
new member of the evening if we get 10
new members I will open up the phone
lines Billy sends a $2.00 super chat do
you think the Department of Justice will
comply with the Moller report subpoenas
I think the most likely scenario is they
comply by the letter and not the spirit
I think the most likely scenario is the
DOJ provides a report that they will
claim has only the minimum necessary
redactions but will actually contain a
number of political redactions that if I
had to bet and I don't bet that would be
the most likely scenario sup man dude
says will trump win in 2020 if Biden
gets the nomination I think that Trump
winning in 2020 is not going to be
primarily influenced by who gets the
Democratic nomination assuming it's not
somebody who really is is unelectable I
think it will be more influenced by
voter turnout and what happens between
now and then with the Trump
administration you made you mosa with a
ten British pound super chat says
hashtag David versus Sam hashtag super
chats keep flowing in smiley face yes
indeed yes indeed I'm gonna see Sam next
week and I was just talking to him I was
texting with him yesterday because
stefan molyneux attacked me on twitter
and we were just chatting about it and
what I should do if anything
Jacqueline spewing spewing with a five
euro super chat thanks to you and your
team for your great work thank you for
your support
Jacqueline n name withheld says the
Trump camp is sitting back and saying
more candidates more candid that maybe
III truly don't think at this point
Trump benefits or or loses if there are
more Democratic candidates at this stage
candidates are going to start dropping
out I think within within three months
some candidates will be gone
don't don't think it's going to impact
from too much one way or the other
gr has reappeared who says either way DZ
there's only two and one has already
lost it the mind where is it I don't
know Pakman I don't know it is not
hopeless love gr thank you very
much I appreciate that and Miko piss
Paula or piss Paula were the five euro
super chat
you called roseanne racist for Planet of
the Apes tweet Rogan called black
neighborhood pota
popota but you let it slide Planet of
the Apes but you let it slide because
you want to get his popular PC to his
popular you want to get to his popular
podcast oh ok
listen I don't know what you're talking
about I've heard of that clip I saw it
years ago and I thought that Joe Rogan
was satirizing racism I could be wrong I
don't know I I just doesn't feel like
that's a huge huge thing for my for my
audience ok let me talk about something
serious and at some point I haven't
addressed this on the broadcast show yet
and the reason why there's a few reasons
why which I'll go into when I ultimately
do but we are sort of experiencing a
minor ad pocalypse 2.0 on our youtube
channel now if you use relatively new to
the channel ad pocalypse 1.0 as it is
now known took place at the beginning of
April of 2017 so it's been basically 2 2
years 2 years almost to the day since
this took place and because of some
advertisers pulling advertising from
YouTube over ads that appeared on racist
content we experienced for about a month
a ninety nine percent drop in our ad
revenue and it absolutely crushed us and
over time ad revenue has sort of
recovered to some degree but also our
channel has really grown so a lot of the
sort of recovery is not so much that ad
revenue has come back on a per view
basis but that our channel now has six
hundred and twenty thousand subscribers
and about ten million views a month when
two years ago it was only getting like
six million a six million views a month
so part of the recovery has been we've
just grown okay
and things have sort of settled in the
last 72 hours I have grown
extraordinarily concerned that we are
experiencing the
early stages possibly have had pocalypse
2.0 and what we are experiencing are
videos that are completely brand safe
get demonetised
i'll give you some examples and in fact
maybe I should pull up our YouTube
channel in order to be able to show this
to you I'll give you some examples from
yesterday's program and this is this is
really not not a good thing where do we
start let me see if I can start where
our yesterday's Clips okay here we go
this video which we put out was our 4:30
clip cringe-inducing candice owens dave
rubin interview is self-parody the
underlying video it was an analysis of
an interview between candice owens and
dave rubin
is monetized i commented on it adding
nothing that is in any way not brand
safe not uh Neffs ec safe
that video was d monetized or put in a
limited monetization state by YouTube we
immediately appeal it can take seven to
ten days for a person to actually look
at the video at which point most of the
videos views have already happened in
this case 43,000 views we will have lost
the revenue by the time the advertising
gets turned back on our Andrew yang
interview fortunately remained monetized
Jordan Peterson not political goes to
extremist Christian University I'm sorry
it's sort of off the screen placed
immediately in a limited monetization
state off to a nice start twenty
thousand views I'm guessing that's a
clip that will end up with seventy to
eighty thousand views eventually
currently earning us no money whatsoever
why I have no idea it's Jordan Peterson
sitting at Liberty University talking on
a panel and me talking about it limited
monetization I'll give you another
example from today obviously this hatred
mail clip is this is it hasn't published
yet that one has been demonetized
and we knew that it would from today's
program this video trump suddenly
against releasing Moeller report which
published just three minutes ago it is
at least
when we looked at it earlier in a
limited monetization state it's about a
Justice Department report for crying out
loud and maybe not anymore it was marked
as mature audiences only it made you
confirm that you understood that there
may be content not suitable for young
people other than the corruption exposed
in the clip I don't know what that could
possibly be that creates viewer
abandonment that makes it so that we end
up earning a fraction of the money that
we normally would on YouTube I've
reached out to my current partner
manager I've reached out to my old
partner manager asking for help I've
reached out to the YouTube beta team
which has nothing to do with
monetization just because we are
desperate this is not good and this is
exactly what I have been sort of
thinking internally which is YouTube
revenue has recovered we cannot count on
it because at any time at the snap of
the finger or at the snap of a change to
the algorithm we lose a significant
portion of that money so it's
particularly important right now that we
continue to do the stories that we think
are important the last thing I want to
do and I wouldn't do this and we didn't
do it during ad pocalypse was to start
picking stories that would remain
monetized the whole point of the show is
we do the stories that I determine are
stories that we should do and the way
that we continue to do that is by
membership support I know some people
are sick of hearing me say it but every
time someone becomes a member that's a
video that doesn't matter whether it's
monetized or not because we're building
our support organically through the
audience okay so I know we talked a lot
about on the live streams if you sign up
I'll open up the phone lines and I will
if we get to ten new members today but
please do if you want the show not only
to continue growing but if you think
it's important as I know most people do
maybe not the trolls for me to do the
stories that matter rather than the
stories that will be monetized and
that's not something I would ever do and
we did it we kept our policy through
I would add pocalypse and we had lost
99% of our revenue the best thing you
can do as a sort of sign of support is
to sign up for a membership the
memberships are really cheap I've got a
coupon code this is 20 20 it'll save you
40% off of any membership I have a
coupon code save 35 which only works on
the $60 a year membership it'll drop a
$60 a year membership to twenty-five
bucks if you can afford two dollars and
eight cents a month that's what that's
roughly what 25 dollars a year is if you
think what we're doing is worthwhile and
it's worth 25 bucks a month I'm asking
for your support it really does make a
difference particularly as we may be in
the early stages of ad pocalypse 2.0
I've talked to you know one of the
reasons I've been talking to so many
other progressive hosts over the last
few days is that it's not just the david
pakman show channel that is experiencing
this so please please please consider
supporting include your coupon your area
code in your name when you sign up and
if we open up the phone lines I will go
to you first I will give priority to the
people that get us to open the phone
line so that's that that's the rant
that's what's going on with YouTube and
it it sucks but the one thing I will say
and I was talking to our partners about
this yesterday giving them a sort of
first quarter report of what's going on
as YouTube revenue recovered over the
last year I always considered it it
considered it speculative erratic and
unreliable for exactly exactly this
reason it's a bummer but it's what we're
dealing with okay I see a lot of people
are sending me messages here Peter cure
any Carini sends a 499 super chap James
boo Chino why does angry andrew yang
make your top three over others I just
have so much political agreement with
Andrew yang there are so many issues on
which Andrew yang and I agree so it's
just a it's a political thing Andrew
yang Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders
I'm ignoring identity for the time being
um they are the three candidates that I
believe I am most aligned with
politically Geraldine nee Maryse Ruis
and
two euros super chat hi David brexit do
you follow it what are your thoughts I'm
not an expert on brexit I am against
brexit the day after it happened I said
it may never happen and I still believe
that that may be the case and I still
believe that that's what would be best
for the UK over the long term so I
follow it casually I guess I would say
Matt McHenry says universal basic income
plus VAT tax and not stacking with
welfare is a yikes I agree and I
confronted Andrew yang about this stuff
on yesterday's at yesterday in today's
interview and he had a lot of the right
answers to my concerns I don't agree
with him 100% about how he would
structure it but I agree with a lot of
it and I think he generally is an honest
actor and totally genuine I just simply
disagree with him about some of the
details of the implementation horror fan
for life says between horror movies my
love of monsters and all things macabre
I can't believe I am living in a real
scary movie like I'm in a nightmare
aka Trump a lot of people agree with you
no question about that
Sam Dean who joins us from Australia
with a 10 Australian dollar super Chad
g'day mate how do you feel about
America's worldwide reputation as an
Australian the whole German dad oranges
windmill stuff might be pretty funny if
it wasn't so frightening thoughts Cheers
yeah listen America's reputation around
the world is in the toilet it is
disgusting what we are experiencing it
is going to take years to recover from
it I don't know how long it's going to
take but it's going to take a long time
and you know if Donald Trump is
experiencing cognitive decline if saying
the noise from wind turbines causes
cancer is a sign of pre dementia if
saying his dad was born in Germany when
his dad was born in New York as a sign
of pre dementia if saying that he wants
to know the oranges rather than the
origins of the Moller probe is a sign of
pre dementia it's not anything to make
fun of it's sad Trump's policies are
disgusting but if he's having a
cognitive issue he shouldn't be
president it's nothing to make fun of
it's sad and it's a danger for the
United States of America
CW hambone anti-imperialist left sand
animus with Leninist left no I I think
being against Empire is one thing and
being part of the so-called Leninist
left is different and there could be
overlap in those groups but I think that
they are I think that there are two
different things
sup man dude says what if Trump doesn't
accept the election results it listen
let's deal with that when we get to it I
think it is extraordinarily unlikely
scenario you know the right accused
Barack Obama of being on the verge of
enacting martial law suspending the 2016
election there was never any indication
he would do that Trump has actually said
he might not accept election results he
the only way he can lose is through
fraud three to five million people voted
illegally
it's kind of cool he likes it I don't
remember his exact phrasing that the
Chinese president is trying president
for life and maybe will try it sometime
there are more reasons to think that
Donald Trump might try to not accept
election results if he loses but let's
deal with that when we get to it I think
American law enforcement is more than
well enough equipped to deal with that
Sabrina Zafar says is the David Pakman
show live show in Boston still a thing
yes I'm actually going on Friday to look
at a possible what I would call it
candidate venue and I'm a little
concerned about the ability to have like
a bar with drinks and snacks and I want
to make sure that the the bathrooms are
suitable the last thing I would want can
you imagine imagine if we have this live
event and the bathrooms are a disaster
and like the the guests that we have are
disturbed by the poor facilities we're
providing them so I'm gonna go check out
a space on Friday I want to make sure
that it will be suitable and then I will
have more more information about that ji
tigner or Tyner is a new member using
the join button down below that's new
member number five for the evening and I
also want to thank Clayton Helmerich who
has signed up for a membership at david
pakman.com slash membership that is new
member number six if we get to 10 I'll
open the phone lines
if we don't I won't I think it's
important if I issue a challenge that I
have to stick to it so only four more
new members and I'll open up the phone
lines if you want priority when we open
the phone lines if we open them include
your area code when you sign up on our
website in either the first name field
or the last name field and if I see an
area code come in with new memberships I
will give you a priority when we open
the phone lines and let you let you
participate before anybody else Jimmy
from Philly oh boy
Jimmy from Philly here I don't even know
if I should let's not even get into it
Jimmy from Philly
sends a $2.00 super chat message not
cent edit and try again Jimmy I don't
know what you're talking about I don't
know what you're talking about but
there's going to be a revelation about
Jimmy from Philly on the show somewhat
soon which I think is going to be maybe
disturbing but probably more sad in
general and Jimmy has been yeah Jimmy's
been leaving voicemail still he we had a
conversation actually about this let's
see what Jimmy is saying the phone line
is closed it'll open if we get 10 new
members let me see what Jimmy had to say
so David Jimmy from Philly here so I
just watched your latest video where
Trump bespeaks and you claimed that this
is pre cognitive decline no it's not
precognitive that would be more like out
of the Minority Report it's just free
dementia or early cognitive decline or
pre dementia and yet the phone
conversation I just had with you a
couple hours ago you claimed that I was
angry on the voicemail I left about the
[ __ ] Nelly when and I told you okay so
he rambles in that one and then he left
another voicemail there's a lot of hang
yep that's just a hang-up from Jimmy
from Philly and yeah so anyway Jimmy
from Philly a lot going on but I
appreciate the $2 super chat enter name
sends a $5 super chat F marry kill
Beyonce Rihanna Taylor Swift that's
interesting let me let me indulge that
let me think about that and by the
this is a horrible this is a horrible
game but I'm gonna indulge it because
I'm doing what the people are calling
for Beyonce Rihanna or Taylor Swift you
know I would probably die I wouldn't
kill anyone but if I had to it's
probably Taylor Swift from those three
and then I would I would marry Beyonce
that that's probably the way it would
shake out for me a new maid you mosa
with a ten British pound super chat is
there any point in debating or
discussing - stefan molyneux when his
fans want to believe the rubbish that he
spouts particularly the rubbish that
black people are supposedly genetically
inferior I I don't think there's much of
a point to debating molyneux cultists
and you know as a goof I mean okay you
know well I'll engage with some of it on
Twitter or whatever but I don't I don't
really think there is much of a point to
it I think it's listener he I didn't
didn't he tear up from happiness about
some some like white guy whites only
gathering it wasn't by definition whites
only but I think that there's like only
almost don't only white people in Poland
guys very weird I think that there's
something something off about him as as
if most of my audience doesn't realize
that already game fire 74 with a
five-dollar 17 cent super chat breaking
New York Times some on Muller's team see
their findings as more damaging for
Trump than Bar revealed what are your
thoughts obvious obvious and let's see
I'm going to copy and paste that I want
to check out that article let me take a
look here okay
17 minutes ago I see an article from
trust org
new Reuters is not very okay so I've got
to find that story yeah that that would
not be even remotely surprising and it
is exactly what I've been saying
although I was way wrong way way way
wrong about everything forever Nouvel
costs says who's your favorite current
US politicians serving at any level
who's your favorite of all time living
or deceased what non-politician should
yeah I I am so III don't I'm not like a
fanboy of anybody I have to say so I
couldn't even say my favorite politician
I don't see these people as in this way
there's people I agree with and people I
disagree with I really struggle because
I'm I don't I don't really have
favorites in that way what non
politician should run you know who I
think would be an interesting elected
official and I'm sure I disagree with
him about stuff but because of his
personality and because of who he is I
think that former Basque I hope he's not
playing anymore I think he's retired
former basketball player Steve Nash who
I think is Canadian anyway I actually
find him interesting as someone who
speaks about politics in a way that I
think is very relatable and has the
right views about a lot of issues just
to name somebody James Buchi no says
what are the ticket prices for the David
Pakman show live in Boston no ticket
prices have been established yet my idea
is that they should be between 15 and 25
bucks I want to make it accessible maybe
if it's 25 it'll include like a drink
ticket or something like that but I
don't I don't want it to be expensive I
want it to be accessible but it's got to
cover the cost and I want to put on a
good event a good event will reigns says
can you expand on the ubi v80
disagreement with Andrew yen okay here's
the thing let me take a sip of water
Andrew yang what the way he wants to
fund universal basic income is through
what's called a value-added tax now a
value-added tax let's see how it's
actually formally defined VAT tax um
okay value-added tax well that's the
wrong framing the value-added tax in the
European Union is a broadly based
consumption tax assessed on the
value-added to goods and services it
applies more or less to all goods and
services that are bought and sold for
use or consumption in the European Union
the disagreement is that when you put a
value-added tax in place percentage-wise
it's regressive now why is it regressive
you might say rich people spend way more
money than
poor people because they have more money
and that's true but on a percentage
basis rich people spend a much smaller
percentage of their money than poor
people because rich people have excess
money which they can save which means
that on a percentage basis poor people
end up paying much more of their income
as a rate to uh VAT tax than rich people
so that's the disagreement I don't like
the VAT tax for that for that reason and
Andrew yang had his perspective and he
presented it on the interview which is
on our YouTube channel X says if you
allow me to moderate I will not
disappoint I'm interested in more
moderators actually let me take this as
an opportunity we are looking to add
moderators to the david pakman show
youtube channel and to the david pakman
show subreddit here's how you apply
we're not doing it via super chat if you
want to be invited to moderate get in
touch with me using the website contact
form at david pakman.com tell me if you
want to moderate on reddit or on youtube
or both and send me a link to your
profile if you want to moderate on
reddit send me a link to your edit
profile if you want to moderate on
youtube sent me a link to your youtube
account you can google how to find a
link to that it's just like your home
channel profile page whatever we need
more people moderating on both Reddit
and YouTube because the channel both
channels keep growing and growing so get
in touch with me I actually are looking
for people and I'm glad that you brought
it up Jimmy from Philly now you're
cutting off my voicemails beautiful yes
I am Jimmy I am chris brown with a 1699
New Zealand dollar super chat do you
think there's a way for foreign
countries to push back against US
influence thinking of the Christchurch
shooter being radicalized by extreme
views being peddled by some groups in
the US um it's tough I mean we live in a
globalized world right now and American
media being so prevalent movies TV shows
what happens in the news it would be
pretty tough
it would be pretty tough unless you do
something very very heavy-handed which I
would probably be against so yeah I
don't know I don't know how you do that
Chris but I understand wanting to I
really do you should see the influence
of American culture in my birth country
of Argentina it's it's truly stunning
let me say welcome to Daniel Cote who
has signed up on our website he is new
member number seven of the evening I
will warn you I'm starting to get closer
to the end of my time this evening so if
people want me opening the phone lines
it's just three more members three more
members we can do this we're talking
about a couple bucks a month Daniel has
included his area code and it looks like
actually he's local to the Boston area
or at least Massachusetts so that means
that if and when we open the phone lines
Daniel and I'm writing down his area
code now we'll be the first caller and
three more new members will open the
phone lines and if you include your area
code in the first or last name field
when you sign up I will go to you first
when I open up the phone lines very easy
it's pretty cheap it's written you know
when I go and do speaking gigs I've not
been Shapiro but you know I command a
speaking fee but for two bucks a month
you can get on the phone with me right
now how about that is Wow how about that
is a sales pitch for you debar News says
if Trump is removed from office from
office is pence actually better no I
think in a lot of ways pence is worse
and I've said it before also get Jesse
Lee Peterson on your live show that'd be
great yeah I don't know I mean the what
I find funny about Jesse Lee Peterson is
when he interviews me his questions are
so wacky and ridiculous that it's funny
to just be interviewed by him and
comment on the questions he really
doesn't like it when you call out his
questions as bogus I don't know that it
would be that interesting if I
interviewed him because he would just
talk about you know Trump the great
white hope and all of this stuff I don't
think it would be that that interesting
but my management my team is in
negotiations for a possible big Jesse
Lee Petersen related event and I'll
announce that is
I'm allowed to James Kirk says hi David
if he wins who do you think Bernie will
select as his vice president do you
think he may go with a female is aoc old
enough I don't think AOC is old enough I
don't know and I'm I'm sort of I
mentioned this earlier I'm not thinking
about VP stuff at this point in time
it's just too early I'm focused on the
candidate period and I I don't know who
Bernie would pick and I don't know who I
would recommend and I think we should
just focus on the primary right now now
my phone is blowing up let me I think I
might have said something that offended
someone no they're not offended they're
liking the stream okay that's good Matt
D says do you think if Trump is the
Republican nominee even though some
Republicans dislike him right now they
would still vote majority a law majorly
along party lines in 2020 of course yeah
I mean if Trump is the nominee he's
going to be the nominee I don't see any
real way that anybody challenges him
successfully it would be great if
someone challenges him enough to weaken
him that I would like to see that but I
think yes Republicans are going to vote
along party lines which is why the left
needs turnout the left needs turnout to
win CW hambone says what distinguishes
the Leninist left okay there is a sort
of true there's a trio or four different
ideas that are common to the Leninist
left one is sort of what's the word I
want to apply to it
not so much concerning but thinly veiled
defenses of authoritarian dictators are
a sign of the Leninist left the defense
of the authoritarian Maduro Chavez
regime is a sign the total irrational
skepticism to anything Russia Trump
related beyond logic and a healthy level
of skepticism is often a sign of the
Leninists left I've got a video line so
you could you could
get out booger stink plop sends a $10
super Chad David I've come to realize a
failing of mine is that I don't seek out
conservative viewpoints and I'm
sheltering myself can you recommend
someone who isn't a psychopath or
carrying water for fox news not really
no I can't I mean I can give you some
ideas of you know here I I don't like
answering this question because I don't
want to promote right-wingers who I
think are doing damage to the country
and you can very easily find people I
think that there are you know that if
you want to read books rather than look
for YouTube clips so there are
definitely what I would call principled
conservatives who I don't find to be
hateful I find that they argue in good
faith I've got a list and maybe I'll do
a clip about that there is a list of
people that I think are sort of
reasonable reasonable people with whom I
respectfully disagree Matt D do you
think it would ever be possible for
stronger gun control legislation given
the power wealth and influence of the
NRA it's possible once we decide that we
are going to change campaign finance and
the lobbyists industrial complex and
once we depoliticize guns in a way where
a significant portion of the country has
to stop fetishizing them I mean that
that has to happen if we're going to
really be able to do anything about gun
control and gun safety otherwise it's
gonna be more of the same
sadly a horror fan for life you and
Howard Stern are my favorite on-air
personalities yeah I was I've been
listening to Howard Stern for probably
20 years very very exciting episode this
morning Richard [ __ ] his pants which is
extraordinarily high level and and
nuanced and insightful commentary but no
I've been I've been a Howard fan for for
20 years and still listen but by the way
he's got to be doing more shows three
days a week with what twelve or fourteen
weeks a year vacation I get that he's
got five hundred million but people want
to hear more of what I know I and I
should say the pop interviews like when
he had um what was that band maybe
someone can tell me
there's a thigh that the number five is
in the band name it's like five it's
it's like a boy band with the with the
number five in it maybe someone can tell
me here in this in the chat five what is
the name of this boy band that is five
dudes and what is that I know someone's
gonna type it any second and then I'm
gonna feel stupid or maybe maybe I won't
feel stupid five guys at the Jackson 5 5
seconds of summer yeah no not maroon 5 5
second 5 by is it 5 seconds of summer
that sounds wrong 5 seconds of summer
yeah when Howard Stern interviewed 5
seconds of summer that's who he would
have been goofing on even as recently as
8 years ago indefinitely 15 what are you
doing what are you doing
ok CW hambone do you think progressive
voice could get away with his business
model if he wasn't an endearing kid
absolutely not absolutely not
and in fact I know there's someone a
friend of mine does the podcast version
of what progressive voice does although
in a slightly more nuanced way no
offence the progressive voice I'm just
say it's an in a less kind of shock
value TMZ type of way and he gets away
with it again because he's doing
something kind of unique and in
particular but no and progressive voice
better be careful he doesn't age out of
everybody allowing allowing him to do
what he does Riley Milburn hey David
have you done any research on Peter Pete
Budaj edge yet his campaign has been
gaining steam recently and I'm curious
what your thoughts are I have done
research on him and I I like his
delivery I like his personality I have
some political disagreements with him
which I'm planning an upcoming clip on I
don't want to get ahead of myself but I
do I do want to comment on him soon and
I think he's a very very interesting
candidate I have seen that in polling
and in fundraising he's starting to see
an uptick and I think it would be very
interesting if he becomes a contender
earlier in the stream I said he would
crush absolutely crush Mike Pence in a
vice presidential debate I think that it
would be an interesting dynamic with
Donald Trump
although different than with Mike Pence
and I will soon be commenting I will
soon be commenting on Pete Budaj edge
and we were trying to get him on the
program a lot of people tweeting to him
and I to him tweeting tweeting to him
and me that I should interview him and I
would love to we've reached out once or
twice and have not heard back sadly but
I he's welcome on the program absolutely
anytime okay on that note I think that's
it for today we sadly have fallen short
of the target of 10 new members to open
up the phone lines and I've got it if we
don't reach it I really should not be
opening the phone lines because
otherwise I'm disincentivizing signups
so I will scream again soon if enough
people get in touch with me and say they
want a live stream tomorrow I will do a
live stream tomorrow but for now this is
it and I appreciate everybody who did
join me tonight